REBECCA CHAVEZ: Welcome back, or
welcome to the second session.
The last talk we're
going to do today
is Getting Code Out the Door.
It's a panel discussion,
as you can see,
so we're really hoping
that it can be interactive,
and we're really going to be
looking for your involvement,
questions and answers.
But first, please allow me
to make a public service
announcement.
Next Wednesday,
March 12 at 6:00 PM,
there's going to be a
Google Developer group,
another panel discussion.
It's going to be here
on Google Campus,
it's open to the public.
For more details,
there's a website,
you can just google
Google Developer Group.
Van in the back has
some details on it.
He's a program manager with
our Developer Relations team.
I also have the details,
so if anyone's interested,
look for one of us
afterwards or google it.
OK.
Cool.
Again, hi.
Some of you have seen
me all afternoon.
I'm almost done.
My name, again,
is Rebecca Chavez,
I'm a technical program manager.
Here on the panel
we have Subha--
I knew this was going to get me.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: Subramanian.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Mhm.
Thank you.
She's a product manager.
We have Anya Kogan, she is
an interaction designer.
We have Irene Chung,
SWE, Software Engineer
here at Google, a
software engineer lead.
So we'll get to hear from her.
Sabrina Williams, she's a
software engineer in test,
she's going to talk to
us about what she does.
And then Sabrina Farmer, and
she is another engineering
lead here on our SRE team.
And so the general idea of
getting code out the door,
we're going to make
it pretty simple.
We're just going to talk
about a very general pipeline.
Again, I mentioned
some of the roles here.
The ladies will
go into what they
do more specifically, but
just to give you a high level.
Subha's role, the
product manager,
it's really the strategic
aspect of Product.
Understanding user
requirements, helping prioritize
feature development.
Anya then makes it the
best experience ever.
So her team really works
closely with Product team
to get the right visuals or
get the right user experience.
Irene, then, her groups are
where the rubber gets the road.
They codify it, they
code that experience.
Sabrina's groups, they
make sure that when
you are launching
this code, you're not,
in the process, breaking
somebody else's code.
They build out the test
suites, and the tooling,
and the framework to
make sure that when
you launch the feature it's
going to work as you expect it.
And then Sabrina Farmer,
her groups just make it run.
There's a lot of unique
challenges to Google's scale
and complexity, and
Sabrina's team really
are the guardians in Production
and making sure that that code,
once it's out there, it's
healthy and running well.
Oh, and I'm a program manager.
I get the opportunity
of working with all
of these different phases, and
it's not like serial at all,
this pipeline.
It's very iterative and
we have an opportunity
to work across, not in this
kind of cyclical idea of product
development.
Yes, I get to work with all
of these really amazing women.
So I'm going to turn it over
and let these ladies introduce
themselves and talk a
bit more about their role
in getting code out the door.
And then we will
go to questions.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: Hi,
I'm Subha Subramanian,
and I'm a product
manager at Google.
Specifically, I work on Google+.
My role is to
basically work on all
of the data that is
created in the stream
and then share it across
other Google products
and with third parties.
I have been at Google
for eight years now,
and I've worked in a
couple different capacities
at Google, as a web developer,
and then as a UI designer,
and I'm now a product manager.
As a product
manager I definitely
have to come up with a
strategy for my product,
and then help prioritize a whole
bunch of different problems
that we could be trying
to solve with the product.
Then see which one of those
we could attack first,
which ones are feasible
to do, and which
ones we need to put
on the back burner.
I end up working with
all of these ladies,
and as Rebecca mentioned, it's
not usually typically like,
first I come up with an idea,
and then I go talk to Anya.
Ideas come from a lot
of different places.
Sometimes Eng comes
up with ideas,
sometimes our users
come up with the ideas,
or we get a mandate
from leadership
like, this is the direction
we should be going in.
Then we'll kind of
think about, OK,
if this is the direction
we need to go in
or if this is the
problem we need to solve,
what is the right
strategy to do that?
How do we get
that, and how do we
do it for the short
term and the long term.
I also end up working
with a lot of other folks
who are not
represented here, folks
who are in security, privacy,
legal teams, et cetera.
I'll let you talk.
ANYA KOGAN: I'm Anya, I'm
the user experience designer,
and my job is to take
the product or business
strategy that someone like
Subha would have come up with
and, with that in
mind, go and talk
to all the various people
who might be using a product.
So in my case, I
work for AdWords,
I've worked for AdWords
for two and a half years.
It's our main
advertising platform
where businesses use to sell
their products and services.
So I will talk to
those businesses,
I will talk to the
people using AdWords,
and get a better
understanding of what
their needs and behaviors are.
Then with that in
mind, I create mockups,
I might create prototypes
using HTML, CSS, JavaScript.
That's about as far
as I get into code.
I'll let the rest of these
ladies handle the rest of that,
and I often partner with
a Tech Lead or a SWE
to help guide me in
understanding what
the constraints are
of the platform.
AdWords in particular
is extremely complex
and I need to be aware
of what's possible.
Also, by partnering
with Engineering,
I get a chance to learn about
everything that's possible
and all the technical
innovation that I
could put into my designs.
Then I hand those designs
over to an engineer,
and then we work
closely together
to ensure the quality
of o product design.
IRENE CHUNG: Hello everybody.
My name is Irene, and
I'm a software engineer,
a technical lead, and a
manager on the Google+ team.
I've been at Google for
about seven and a half years,
and I previously also
worked on AdSense, Buzz,
and Google Calendar.
The role of the
software engineer
is actually to really focus
on building the right product
and getting that shipped
at the right time.
So a lot of our work,
we work very closely
with product and user
experience experts
to make sure we're defining
the right experience together.
A lot of it is a balancing
act in terms of making sure
that what we're building is the
right technical solution that
scales properly
and is extendable,
but also something that
we can get to users very,
very quickly.
And on the other
side, we also get
to work with the Production
folk, so test engineering,
also release engineering and
site reliability engineering,
and just making sure
that we have the latest
best practices in place.
That is pretty much
impervious to anything
that the world can throw at us.
SABRINA WILLIAMS: Hi,
I am Sabrina Williams,
I am a software
engineer in test.
I've been at Google for
two and a half years now.
I'm on the Glass team,
but before that, I
was on Chrome working on
something called Cloud Print.
So I'm actually going
to take this opportunity
to explain a couple
of different roles,
because people think
they're the same thing.
We have two roles called Test
Engineer and Software Engineer
in Test.
A test engineer is more
of your typical Q--
I won't even say typical QA,
but it's more like your QA type
role where they're in
charge of the test plans,
they do work in
automating tests,
they're the user
advocate, they make
sure that what they decide
the product is supposed to do,
the test engineer makes
sure it actually does that.
The software engineer
in test, I think of it
more as a productivity engineer.
We help make everybody
else more productive.
We create frameworks,
if a test engineer
is trying to figure out
how to automate something,
we'll help them figure
out how to do that.
If the software engineers
are figuring out
how to design their
code so that it's
more maintainable
long-term, we'll
help them figure
out how to do that.
We are very focused on
quality and making sure
that the development environment
produces quality code
at the end of the day.
So that's pretty much what I do.
SABRINA FARMER: And
I am Sabrina Farmer,
and I am a site reliability
engineer here at Google.
I've been at Google,
now, for nine years,
I think in two days or
something like that.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN:
Happy anniversary.
SABRINA FARMER: Site
reliability at Google
is essentially a peer team
with the software engineers,
but our focus is
on the production
side of running
the product, which
includes failover and
includes capacity management
and performance of the products.
We're often the first
responders to issues
when they are identified, either
with scaling or difficulties
in the infrastructure.
What we do is we work with
each of these different parts
of engineering to, at the
early stage, when the product
managers say hey,
we want to do this,
we explain the speed of
light, which is often
required with the new features
that they want to add.
Then we work with the software
engineers during the design
phase to make sure
they understand
the infrastructure
that they're running on
and some of the limitations
of that infrastructure
so they can work around that.
Site reliability is about 50% of
software engineers, 50% systems
engineers, and so we often
have to build the systems that
would mitigate the
different kinds of failures.
So how users are
distributed globally,
that's often something
that the SREs will develop.
So that's the kind
of engineering we do.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Great.
So Irene, she touched
on it a little bit,
of the balancing act
that is engineering.
And I was curious if we could
quickly go through maybe
what are some trade-offs
in your role that you see,
like getting code
out the door, what
are the constraints or the
trade-offs that you have
to make when either you're
forced to get something out
by x date or maybe a major
bug fix, something like that.
So maybe some
trade-offs that you guys
do when you're getting
code out the door.
SABRINA FARMER: I think for
SREs, some of the things
that we have to often work
with the different teams
on-- because they really care
about the velocity of getting
things out the
door-- and when you
work on a product
like GMail, you're
going to instantly hit
millions and millions of users
all at one time.
So we often have to put controls
in front of the releases
that they want to
do, and phase it out.
So we put a lot of
limitations on what they do
and how often we want it-- how
slowly it needs to roll out,
and things like that.
They're driving towards
getting it out the door
as soon as possible,
we're doing it
so that we want to minimize the
impact to the user or the risk
to the user.
We often compromise on that.
IRENE CHUNG: I would also
add that trade-offs are just
kind of a fact of life.
It's just something that
you have to be prepared for.
What we try to do when
we look at trade-offs
is make informed,
intentioned trade-offs.
So actually looking at what are
the reasons why we're actually
doing something, what is the
right path to the long term
ideal, and then what are the
right increments that you
can do quickly to meet any
sort of demands or deadlines
that need to happen.
As long as they're made
with informed intention
and you have a path to the ideal
solution, they're usually OK.
But it's just something
that we work through.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Anyone else?
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN:
Well, I mean, I
can add that
sometimes we may need
to leave certain
features out if we're not
able to make those
part of the release.
So that's one of the
trade-offs that we
may be making sometimes.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: OK.
Anybody from the audience have
any questions about the roles,
or maybe some of the challenges?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: You didn't
say what you did.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Oh, sorry, yes.
So I'm a technical
program manager,
and I usually describe
that as a project manager.
So I get engaged in efforts
that can be very large in scope,
from across Google,
and coordinating
many different engineering
teams or functional areas,
to something maybe more intimate
and specific, working maybe
with Engineering.
Like a specific team for
either a feature launch
or optimizing their velocity.
So the TPM role at Google
is, in my opinion, I love it.
There's a lot of opportunity
to apply different skills
at different times.
And then, of course,
you get to work
with all of these cool people.
We have, also, a mic.
So if anyone doesn't hear the
question, we'll repeat it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question for
the software engineers.
How quickly or how regularly
do deployments happen,
and how does that affect a
timeline of releasing new
features out on
the Google+ team.
IRENE CHUNG: Sure.
So on the Google+ team, we
actually developed a method
of releasing code to production
every single business day.
This is unprecedented at
Google, previous to that
I believe the record
holder was Gmail, which
managed to get the production
release schedule down
to once a week.
Then we sort of stole
their release engineer
because he's awesome.
We basically gave
him all the resources
he needed and said
make this better.
Do what you can to make
this absolutely awesome,
so we can get features to our
users as quickly as possible.
So it's actually a really
interesting process.
I would say that
everybody's involved,
so there are a core set
of release engineers
who are responsible for making
sure the thing ships every day.
But we have an
on-call rotation that
includes software
engineering, it includes test,
it includes all other
aspects of the pipeline
to make sure that you're really
aggressive about rolling back
code that is broken.
Instead of saying
slowly debug the error,
when you have hundreds
of engineers writing
into a single code base, look
at what is the root cause,
roll that back, and then you
can roll it forward again
with the correct fix.
That way, we have
a clean cut that
goes to production
every single day.
We usually also have a different
test build every single day
that test is working with.
So we have this very clean
pipeline that goes through,
and each day we make
sure it happens.
I think we've only missed maybe
two releases or something.
I'm not sure.
It's some very small
single digit number.
SABRINA FARMER: I
think people often
think that releasing more
frequently adds a lot of risk,
right?
But it actually takes
away a lot of risk,
because you're not
releasing something
that has hundreds of
features all at one time that
are trying to work together,
and then you have a problem
and you have to figure
out exactly what happened.
So releasing more
often is actually
mitigating your
risk to your users.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Great.
Let's see, here.
Oh yeah, a question over here.
We've got the mic, sorry.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question for Subha.
You mentioned that you moved
from an engineering role
to a product management role.
What were the sort
of skills that you
had to learn as you
moved into this new role,
and how did you help
a product move out
or the code move out of the
door by learning these skills?
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN:
I think what I
had to learn was I needed
to kind of come out of this,
like, I'm going
to sit at my desk
and do my role, versus
learning a little bit more
about what are the problems
and learn to prioritize
those problems better and
say, which of these are
more meaningful to tackle first.
So get my head out of the
part that I was focused on
and think broadly
across the product.
And what is the second part
of your question, I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: It's just how
have these skills helped you
in getting code out of the door?
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: How
have these skills helped me
in getting code out the door.
So like I mentioned in the
beginning, a lot of my work
is actually acting as liaison
between the different teams
that I work with.
So product management
is definitely not like,
I'm not the one
writing all the code
and getting things out the door.
I think my part
is to actually be
an evangelist for the
product and to keep
selling the product, both to
people in upper management
and kind of saying,
hey, this is a feature
that needs to go out the
door, this will really
have this impact
on this product.
But also to sell it
to everybody else.
For example to Anya,
who says, but how
is this going to help our users?
Right, because that's going
to be her first question.
And so kind of get buyoff from
people on what we are building,
and to then get it
through the [INAUDIBLE]
so we can get it out the door.
Sure.
REBECCA CHAVEZ:
All right, sorry.
IRENE CHUNG: I
think microphones.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Yeah, sorry,
we'll get to everyone.
AUDIENCE: So do you have any
advice for smaller companies
that maybe don't have
the resources to have
teams and teams of
highly talented people?
Are there things that
maybe can be streamlined
in the process, in the pipeline,
getting started to build up
an organization with
that sort of resource?
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: Sorry, was
your question directed at me?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: In general.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: In general.
Would anyone like to--
SABRINA WILLIAMS: Yeah.
One thing I would
say for sure is
to make sure that you take
advantage of open source tools.
Anything from a continuous
build environment,
to project tracking tools,
to bug tracking tools,
using automated test
framework-- first of all,
anything you can automate
will help save you manpower
because you don't have
to have manual testers,
and don't have to pay
them to manually test
your stuff if it's
automated, and you
can run it continuously.
So setting those sorts
of systems up early
is really, really helpful.
ANYA KOGAN: And I can
also add that if it's
a user-facing tool or feature or
product that you're working on,
just go and talk to people who
will be using your product as
soon as possible,
even if you don't know
exactly what questions
to ask or don't
know the process to follow.
Just talking to them and
telling them what you're doing,
you'll already get a lot
of feedback and insight,
and better get that
earlier rather than later.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: And I would
also just quickly add,
general framework, keeping
things light and adaptable.
So not really going
in and prescribing
any sort of process, but
really looking at the workflow
and figuring out, OK, maybe this
is where we can tweak it a bit
to make it a little easier.
That would just be seconding
all the other comments there.
ANYA KOGAN: It looks
like she's been--
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: After being
here for a whole day
and seeing so many women,
I feel like girls really
do run the world, or
maybe women run the world.
Or maybe even that
women run Google,
but I know that may
not be the case.
What is it like working
here, what challenges
did you face to get here
and work here every day,
and are women running
Google or having
a serious impact on
Google and the way that it
seems right now.
Because it just seems
like there are no men.
[LAUGHTER]
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Great.
Well, there certainly
are men at Google,
but Google is very
interested in women
in leadership and
diversity of the workforce.
So I think we all probably have
different experiences, but also
similar experiences.
That I feel, as a woman at
Google, I'm very supported.
And as Kimber mentioned, if
you are there and believing
in yourself to go do it, really
I don't see any restrictions.
Certainly not at Google.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: Yeah.
I want to add that I
mentioned that I've been here
for eight years, and it's only
I think in the last two or three
years I have noticed that
when I go into meeting rooms,
I'm no longer the
sole woman there.
In fact, I worked on the display
ads team prior to coming onto
the Google+ team, and I've
worked with Anya before.
There was actually
meeting in which
there were eight women, three
of whom were technical leads,
Anya was representing UX,
there was a tech editor
who was a woman, and there
were no men in the room.
And we all just went
like, what happened here?
And we have a lot of mentoring
programs for women too.
And I know Sabrina is
on quite a few of those,
she was just mentioning
to me earlier.
SABRINA WILLIAMS: Yeah,
golly, where to start?
SABRINA FARMER: Both of us.
Both Sabrinas.
SABRINA WILLIAMS: Both Sabrinas.
One thing I'll add
is that I think
this is a really great
company for two reasons.
One reason is because we
have a lot of programs
that are supporting
any sort of minority,
either women, or
a racial minority,
or gender orientation,
all that kind of stuff.
So it's really nice that
we support those things,
but it's also really
neat because when you're
part of Google, and get
to be a part of supporting
those things, and it
actually supports yourself
in a weird way.
I've actually become
much more comfortable
as a black female
engineer since I've
been here because of all of
the things that Google does.
I don't want to get into a big
list of those sorts of things,
but I'd be happy to talk
to anyone afterwards
who wants to find out more
about programs that we have.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my question
is for Subha and Irene.
When you mentioned
daily releases of code,
I was totally baffled.
I worked at Expedia in the past,
and we had reduced our cycle
from six months
down to two weeks.
Beyond that, we didn't
even think about daily.
So what kind of challenges
do you face as a developer,
and even for a product manager,
when you lay out the feature,
do you divide the iterations?
That these are the
dates that you meet,
and how do you even get
to it on a daily basis?
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: I'll let
Irene answer her part first.
IRENE CHUNG: Sure.
So I'll take a
first hack at that.
How do we get to daily releases?
One is just a very, very good
tools and very good hygiene.
So a lot of what the software
engineering and test team does
is making sure that we have
a lot of automated processes
in place that can
automatically catch the code
and run tests on things.
So when you check
something in, you
should within a few
minutes to a few hours,
depending on what you're
running, whether or not
that broken anything.
That's the first layer.
And then we also have
manual testers in place
who do the next layer.
So every single
day, we have a cut
that goes out which the
test team takes a hard look.
They start filing
bugs immediately.
So when we come into work the
next morning as engineers,
we can start boiling
down this list
and looking at things very
directly as this is release
blocking, this is
not release blocking.
So there's very good hygiene
about saying what is blocking,
what is not.
And then when
things are blocking,
you go and you chase
those things down.
Those are the things
that we would say,
you don't leave your
desk until you're
done finding out what the
root cause actually is
or getting it to the right team.
Because a lot of times it
may not be in your code base,
but it may be in
somebody else's.
And it's all about fast
response, fast routing.
So just really good
hygiene and really good
tools for getting
that stuff through.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: For
my part, I actually find
it makes my life a lot easier,
because if the release date was
like two weeks away
and we didn't make it,
and then we have to wait for
two more weeks to release it,
it's actually a pain.
So if it didn't make
the next day's cut,
then we'll make the day
after that if possible.
So it actually streamlines
the development cycle
and helps us get the
product out the door faster.
AUDIENCE: So do you divide it
on a daily basis, when you--
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: So I don't
know if you are talking more
about dividing the release,
like what goes out when.
We do have a sense of timeline
of what goes out when.
Sometimes that is actually
complicated by the fact
that there are different
teams involved in it,
so it's a cross-functional
team launch.
So we are not very
specific about, it
has to go out on x day.
If we couldn't make x day, we
know why we couldn't make it
and we know how we can fix it.
We'll really aim to get it out
the very next possible moment
that we can.
So we are not
really tied down to,
we didn't make it on this
day, now what do we do.
IRENE CHUNG: I would say,
also, there's generally
an understanding of it goes
out when it's ready to go out.
We do all our best
efforts to basically say,
here's a code completion
date that we're
targeting based on the
estimates and the features we've
agreed upon.
We communicate very, very
early if that's not actually
going to happen so that we
can throw the right resources
behind actually
saying, well, is it
just we can put more
engineers behind this
and it can happen, or do
we need to cut something
and that can happen, or is
the date just not important
and it's more important to
get the right experience
out a little bit later.
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: I
would agree with that.
IRENE CHUNG: It's a
lot of communication.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Do we have-- OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm curious about the
specific distinctions
at Google between the product
manager and the program
manager, and about how
those two teams of managers
work together to balance the
priorities on their engineers
between Google-wide
projects as well
as product-specific projects.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Do
you want to go first?
SUBHA SUBRAMANIAN: OK.
So as I mentioned
earlier, my role
is more to look at the strategy
and come up with the features
that we can ship to
make the product better.
Things get really
complicated when
you're talking
about multiple teams
across different functions.
For example, a launch that
we did recently with Google+
and the local team.
Those kinds of things can
get really complicated,
because then you have two
sets of product managers, two
sets of UI designers,
basically everything.
And plus, they talk
to backend teams,
we talk to backend teams, all
kinds of fancy stuff like that.
And then project managers
or program managers really
come in and help us all see the
timelines, keep us on our toes,
and they're the ones that
really drive the project through
and make sure that
it goes on time.
And Rebecca can
speak more to that.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Yeah, right.
So we do partner very closely.
Project managers
are usually the ones
talking schedules and
timelines and priorities,
and trying to help fit
this sequence of work
and development together
for a reasonable outcome,
whether it be a feature launch
or something along those lines.
We all partner together,
the program managers
and the product-- thank you.
I think we have time, maybe,
for one more question.
OK.
And we can always pick
it up afterwards as well,
just find us.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm a UX designer, so this
is mostly directed at Anya.
One of the themes that
came up several times
in the earlier talk
and sessions is
the importance of prototyping.
So I was wondering what
the role of prototyping
is at Google in getting
code out the door?
ANYA KOGAN: A really
important one.
So it is product dependent.
I think people throw different
products, the prototype,
and using different tools.
We typically do have
at least one or two
dedicated prototypers
per product group.
So in my case with AdWords,
we have one prototyper,
and she's actually doing
some amazing work right now.
And it's another she.
Collaborating with
prototypers across all
of ads, which is really,
really big group,
to create a single prototyping
platform, which is basically
a set of established CSS, a
set of widgets that we can all
share so that we can more
quickly produce the prototypes.
So that's been
really awesome, it's
made it a lot faster and
easier to create them.
And as far as what is the role?
We often use them to
sell a product idea,
sometimes we use
them for reviews.
Any time people see
things moving and seeing
things actually interacting,
it's a lot easier
to sell that design idea.
Somehow click-through
mocks don't always
have that same wow factor.
As far as the role,
I think it's to sell,
to demonstrate functionality.
Especially transitions,
for instance,
which you can't really
do with static mocks.
And also, of course,
usability testing.
I think it's a lot
easier to test something
that you can actually
interact with than have
to linearly clickthrough.
IRENE CHUNG: If
it's OK, I'd like
to give an example
of a great prototype
that we had experience with.
I don't know how many of you
are familiar with the Google+
rewrite that we delivered
last year during IO 2013,
but it was a total rewrite
of the system that introduced
a multi-column grid that had
responsive layout and morphed
between multiple different
columns based on your browser
size.
Now, it would have been really
difficult to try this out
on production quality code
really, really quickly.
So we had a couple different
prototypers actually
build this prototype,
do user testing with it,
actually say these are
the features that we want,
these are the features that
we thought were really awesome
but actually, once
we wrote them,
they really don't want them.
And that was a very good
way of testing out new ideas
extremely quickly
and iterating quickly
without having to build on
the production stack, which
can take a lot longer.
So we use prototyping
a lot to make sure
that these ideas are
fleshed out and that they
are solid before we actually
dedicate a lot of engineering
time to them as well.
REBECCA CHAVEZ: Great.
Well, thank you for attending
and thank you, panelists.